[Music]
Runk here we go I will be in El Paso
Texas this week and Albuquerque New
Mexico and then I'm going to be in
Canada Colona BC that may be sold out
I'm not sure Vancouver sold out and then
I added another one so go to Vancouver
February 10th chris.com uh then I got
Rochester kitner Ontario sheveport
Louisiana Houston Texas Corpus Christie
Durham North Carolina and norfol
Virginia I got a bunch of new dates
coming up soon too uh let me uh check
Chris le.com and check it out uh we and
um you can also stream my special grow
or die at chia.com thank you very much
for everything and here we go we are
getting into the next episode of
[Music]
congratulations conratulations
dude let me let's see let me let me get
into high octane
podcast uh mode with the magic mind look
at this little bit here makes me feel
cool doing
it like a shot glass cuz I don't
drink and um that's
it yo uh I feel like
um I don't know I was in I travel so
much dude I was in Phoenix
um I was there I actually had a great
time let me just start off by saying
this by by talking about this actually
Phoenix I I'm I want to kind of move
there dude it's
so awesome the people are so cool yeah
there's you know I don't know there's
bad versions of people everywhere right
like in Hollywood it's like or in La
it's like you know either the dudes that
are like two too cool or too famous or
they'll stab you you know and in Phoenix
it's
like too broy or you know too Hoy I
don't know I feel like you get I feel
like there's a lot of chyia in in
Phoenix but it's like if you're
not getting camid in Phoenix it's
probably good just good it's hot as [__]
that's how I like it I like it
hot um and it was raining the last two
times I went there which was odd and
they told me it was odd but I went to
Phoenix I did my show at celebrity
theater I performed too much in Phoenix
I feel like i' I go there all the time
and perform and it's so fun um but we
were able to do the Celebrity Theater
brought out Denny love he said he had
the best set of his light life that's
the in the round theater uh the the
Phoenix in Phoenix is the Celebrity
Theater it's in the round and I really
like being in the round because I like
being I like when people are looking at
my ass too that doesn't happen too much
on a prenium stage hey he's classically
trained but um
anyway uh he's not classically trained
but uh he's a little trained he went to
NYU for a little bit until got really
pissed off as at his speech at his
speech um teacher because he because his
my contact fell out and I was looking
for it on the ground and she walked
across it purposely and tried to stomp
on it so I good boy that made me mad um
but we don't hold grudges actually I was
thinking about this man people who hold
grudges and do Revenge stuff are wild I
I was just watching this thing on
Netflix this guy was like I didn't
finish it I'll talk about it next time
but it this guy was he was like doing
something to like exact revenge and I'm
just like
man are you that kind of guy are you
that kind of person that's like someone
does something to you I'mma get back at
him I'm really not and maybe I should be
more that guy you know um but I just
feel like it's so much energy that you
have to you
know maybe if it's like a little thing
you know a fun thing but if it's like a
a real [__] over I just get too sad
about things and I don't ever want to
get like I should get more hardcore I
should become
real I should start dressing in suits
honestly and just be a real vindictive
dude that's how I should start doing it
shave you know what I mean slick back
hair cuz my hair looks ill as [__] when
I slick back but it doesn't stay slick
back because you know it gets real puffy
after that sucks and gel's not cool
unless you're in the 90s or Asian
so um anyway I was in Phoenix had a
great time dude I actually let's I went
there we stayed with uh my mother-in-law
I brought the whole family out stayed
with my mother-in-law and uh they all
came to the show and and let
man something happened that I will never
never forget I will straight up never
forget in my life and it was such a
beautiful moment and I know this podcast
is funny and we try to make it La you
know laugh or whatever I don't know but
this is just I have to share this
because it's so
unbelievable so I get out I do the Show
crowd is phenomenal I have a great it's
all new material from grow or die it has
nothing to do with grow or die it's all
new so this is the first time I'm doing
it in a theater from front to back and
I'm like you know when I first came back
and started to do standup I had the
grower die set which was the Don't Push
Me Tour it's confusing but um I did it I
did Phoenix First I did the same theater
first and uh so I'm now back here doing
my new material and I haven't done it
really in a theater yet so I do it it
goes really really well like I'm I I'm
I'm having flashbacks to the last time I
was in Phoenix at the Celebrity Theater
anyway I had a great time time I'm about
to get off stage and I look over to
my well I guess I look forward cuz I
just I I turned to look because you can
turn anywhere because this is a full
circle stage so I turned to look and I
see my wife holding Calvin Billy was
asleep with you know he was with my
mother-in-law she was babysitting and
and she's holding Calvin and I I motion
to I'm like you guys want to come out
and I can and she goes like this no I
could tell Calvin didn't want to come
and it was really loud he doesn't like
loud
noises even on the way out he like the
plane's loud and I was like and and and
Chrystal was like well let me find your
your headphones I'm like no no no no
don't find the headphones let him deal
with it come on we got we can't raise a
someone who's soing wet right let him
take your hands away from your ears
don't be soing wet you know so she was
like oh okay you know because the other
day we had a a conversation about how we
didn't want to raise two spping wets so
um so so he doesn't want to come out so
that's okay so I say good night
everybody and I and I go and I I I go
walk over Calvin is in my wife's arms
and he's going like
this like he's so happy that I'm coming
at back and that he's doing my son gets
so excited that he starts sounding like
Peter Griffin it's not I'm not even like
he actually does he's
goes and he's doing like that and then
he jumps into my arms like throwing
caution to the wind jumps into my arms
and it was like really adorable and I go
oh my God he holds me so tight and I'm
holding him so tight and I bring him
down to the ground because um you know
I'm going to I want to hug him but I
want him to be standing while I'm
hugging him and I'm hugging him and as
I'm hugging him it lasts for a while you
know they say never break the hug first
when your kid's hugging you which I I
just learned that that's a new that's a
tip that's a life life hack I heard is
that you just you wait until they break
away because you want them to know as
much love as they need right so I'm like
yes I'll store that in my Pentium I dude
we're getting the dell and I'm uploading
that that first right I'm into it like
I'm so down with a with a fact like that
right and um I put my son down he and
and and and the crowd's still cheering
you know and my son
actually grabs my shoulders push pulls
me away looks in my eyes he does it with
intent he takes my shoulders pulls them
away from him and then looks into my
eyes and he says simply he says I love
love you
and it was so unbelievable dude it was
so
unbelievable he just pulled me away and
said I love you he didn't say Dad he
didn't say you know what he didn't say
hey this that the other thing he said
three words and it was just I love you
and it was so sweet and it was the first
time that I felt
him
proud of me you know what I'm
saying you know he's almost four next
month but it was the first you know we
have a fun time I make him laugh you
know he he shares stuff with me I share
stuff with him but it was the first time
I felt where he was like wow I'm proud
that my dad does that look at how cool
my dad is and it is something I will
never forget there have been three times
in my
life where something has happened and I
will never ever and I and and as soon as
it happened I thought well you know what
I will never forget that and one of them
was when I was at the movie theaters
when I was watching Casino it was with
me and my brother my mom and my dad and
the and the couple behind you know
whenever Casino came out I don't know it
was in the 90s but I was young my
brother was even younger and the the mom
behind us not our mom but the mom behind
us at the credits she said look at this
parents of the Year to my mom and dad
and my dad was like cuz we were young
you know and they're putting people's
heads and vices and [__] in that casino
movie and and my dad dude one thing you
don't
do is talk [__]
to my
dad after he sees a Scorsese movie you
know what I'm saying my dad grew up in
New York and is Italian and is very Meek
and cool but dude don't approach him
with [__] talk after he's watching a
scorsi
movie trouble trouble at the laat United
Artists
Theater so she says look at this parents
of the A and he says what you think you
could raise these kids better than me my
dad goes full on you think you can raise
these kid why don't you take these kids
home you think you can raise them better
than me huh and he says and then the
husband's like pushing her away like get
he said yeah get out of here and my dad
said and and if your husband had any
balls he'd come over in here and fight
me you fat pig and I go well I'll never
forget
that and of course i' never tell that
story until my dad was retired
but dude I'll never I go oh my
God and I felt proud of my dad too then
too I'll tell you that much because he
stood up for his kids but I was like you
know 14 or something but
anyway um that was the only time I ever
seen my dad really do that it was really
wild you get jacked after you see
certain movies right
um yeah so and then there was another
thing that happened that I I I I thought
well I'll never forget that and actually
right right now it escapes my mind so
maybe I can only hold two at once and so
that Calvin one is I'm more than happy
to just keep that one that one was
amazing it was amazing dude I was at I
was
um it was great and then he was just
like
so I don't know it just really sweet I
had such a great time in Phoenix man and
uh brought my whole uh in-law like the
in-law side of the family out and it was
crazy because I talk about such like
wild [__] on stage now and I was like I
I got to warn you guys like cuz you know
they're like 60 something I'm like you
got to I don't know who's coming I said
to my mother-in-law I was like you you
know but I I get pretty pretty out there
with my material and she was like oh no
we we love we love it it's all good and
it was dude and let me tell you
something it was okay and then the next
day
dude uh we woke up I woke up at 1 [__]
yeah dude when he get dude when someone
can watch your
kids you wake up at 1 dude you wake up
at 1 and you don't feel you don't feel
bad about it at
all um woke up at 1 went to go get
coffee and it was on dude and then I
went to the desert ridge improv and I
met Brian Kalen and I did stand up uh
for his crowd uh and then we roasted
each other afterwards a video is coming
on my other YouTube channel be ready for
it dude
now let me ask you a question Brian Ken
how come when I'm with you I also always
have to meet 12
guys you have too many people around you
all the time and that's very weird
because you're not Eddie
Griffin and that's very weird because
you're not Chingy and that's very weird
because you're not bis Marquee in 1988
and that's very weird do you know what I
mean
why you're not Murphy Lee and that's
very
weird I don't know why but every time I
go to to to see Brian Callen somewhere
and here's the deal dude we're really
good
friends
um and we hang out mostly at business
stuff and you could tell that because
you find me on a place of business but
you could find it you you you mostly
hang out of business stuff right um and
we hang out of business stuff podcasts
you know stand up sometimes we'll shoot
a video together sometimes we'll
sometimes we'll hang out but not often
often it's a business up whenever I see
them there are also 12 guys with him and
it is
always
always always there are always four like
four guys that own a
gym you know three of them will be will
own one gym and then one of them will
own a separate gym and then there will
be some sort of criminal around too
always and I'm telling you
always and then there's like a
45-year-old hot chick somewhere that is
dating one of them and then another guy
that like I I didn't even like once I
leave I completely forget him and I'll
never think of him again but it's always
hey Brian count I don't want to also and
you know what bring 12 guys around for
real bring 12 guys around but don't
introduce me to them cuz I don't know
them and I'm going to now you know oh
I'll give you because he be like oh I'll
give you the give got that friend like
I'll give you the number you guys can
connect next time you're out here you do
the
okay nice enough the nicest guys but I
remember one time I
was I was like yeah I was doing the
Irvine Improv this was a long time ago
and he's just one of those guys dude
where he says oh dude my friends want to
come to your show they're so good
they're so cool can we just can you get
them a ticket can you meet them after I
said okay yeah dude it was like some
dude that was 50 something and two
25-year-old drunk like uh like actual
porn actresses and they were just like
Hey we're friends at Brian K he was like
hey was his name was something like
[__] bbop you know and I'm just like
and I'm like
Brian
don't
don't anyway I met 12 guys one of them
was Sammy the bul gravano you know for
real honestly one of them was Sammy the
bul gravano and I'm like okay he did 24
years in prison really charismatic dude
he's basically jesi you know really
charismatic dude um living in Arizona
and
you know impressive to say the
least and crazy dude I feel like if I
even talk about him I get in
trouble yo the mafia do you know what I
mean the
mafia like not like him aside like it
existed hey the mafia existed dude hey
like like organized crime is to me
hilarious
because crime is crime the fact that
they label it it's like you don't need
to organize if it's organized who it's
still bad like I don't understand why
they say organized crime it gives it
such a romantic Vibe just say crime I
feel like less people would be
Gangsters Organized Crime it's like it
makes it sound nicer and romantic it's
like it's like organized pyromaniacs
yeah we burn down houses but we all do
it in like a steady fashion and we do it
together it's like you're still
[__]
um and so organ hey we're organized
we're organized uh farters that's what
we do oh really yeah does it stink like
[__] oh my God so bad but we all line up
and we just let gas come out and it's
[__] absolutely amazing don't go
against us we'll pin you down with f on
you um so anyway oh you get mouthy with
me hey what did you just say to me hey
Tony put put them down carine come here
open them
up there we go organized
farts don't [__] with the flatulence
family so dumb um
but hey you're breaking my hey hey chill
out you're breaking my wind
um I'm breaking wind in here uh so
anyway hey give me more provalone I got
I got somewhere to
be hey you got d hey give me that
[__] hey look give me
the um what do you call it the [__]
godamn it what's the stuff with this
pistachios in it Mortadella give me the
Mortadella dude you put one by yo if you
stand in a room at Mortadella you pass
gas period there's just it's just fart
Central it's got it's baloney with
pistachios in it hey who figured it out
a fat Italian you
know his name was Mortadella um
per moradell was his name anyway
um so
uh so yeah organized crime dude crazy
[__] would just like murder
people what about distress
dude let me tell you something if I was
an
organized okay this is coming from a guy
who's never broken the law never broken
the law ever except for the speeding
right like the the M you Jay walking
but like would be terrified I stole a
hat once I I've told that story here I
stole a hat once it was bright green and
I thought if I could walk out of
here while I pay for my other stuff with
the hat on and not get stopped then I
deserve the Hat what a lunatic but I did
and it was that Savon drugs got that and
I walked out with the hat it was a hat
it I remember it was before Monster
Energy drink but it was like it looked
like the Monster Energy logo I was
22 that was a mistake and I shouldn't
have done it but I did it I should still
have that hat honestly but anyway
um like people do that and then
they don't stress about it or they
do and it's
like
don't wh what's the price of that stress
what's the price of that stress you
know I I don't think there is a price on
that stress say you robbed a bank and
you knew you robbed a bank you got away
with it and you made you know 1.5 I
don't know I don't know how how much
does a [__] bank have I have no idea
once how much depends what bank right
but say you just rob you get $2
million that's worth the worth the
stress of there's video surveillance of
you with like a a hoodie over your head
you know it's you nobody knows it's you
but that doesn't stress you out enough
to I I can't organized crime crazy
dude um especially like having a lot
like like uh uh what do you call it um
having to uh rely on people you know and
you know we don't talk right we don't
talk to anybody and then some guy
because there's always that one [__] up
that is going to talk right you trust
people
ahra you TR hey we took the blood hey we
bled and we put it on a [__] players
card and then we kissed it and ate it
and then Mortadella [__] it out dude you
know it's like you can't trust
[__] but the people who can't
who say trust no one they trust the most
people
dude cuz they're always criminals trust
no one trust no one that's what [__]
like gangsters yeah trust no one [__]
blood [__] trust no one and then what
they do they turn on them you think
these [__] are doing years not
snitching dude they
snitch look at [__] uh what's his
name Candy brigh rapper guy 69 he
snitched I guarantee this [__]
said trust no one way more than me cuz
I'm all like trust some
people I'm like trust two or three
people I'm like trust one or two people
really well I'm like honestly
I'm like trust one person you know like
fully trust one person this is my [__]
people say trust no one I say fully
trust maybe one person and then kind of
trust also maybe two three people that's
my [__] that I should make a shirt like
that fully trust maybe one person and
then kind of trust two or three people
that's the [__] new merch idea dude
that's going to be banging honestly
that's going to be banging because you
can't not trust anybody you not trust
anybody you get cancer later on in life
you get cancer
you don't trust anybody you just like
move in the shadows and Trust zero
people you can't [__] cancer later
you have live a li a nice life you trust
people with your vulnerabilities with
your emotions you trust at least one
person your wife your husband whoever
you live a beautiful life you trust
maybe two or three other people and they
don't backstab you maybe they do maybe
they don't maybe they backstab you maybe
you have a lesson you learn maybe they
don't backstab you you don't you know
you still liveed your lovely life
trusting two or three
people it's
beautiful I I don't like that trust
nobody [__] and I love Tupac and Tupac
used to say trust nobody trust no one I
guarantee if Tupac didn't get shot and
grew up he'd be like yeah Chris I
actually agree with you I think trust
maybe one person and kind of trust two
or three
people you
know I don't I don't know is this even
plugged
in oh man it looks like it's not plugged
in I oh it is plugged in okay cool hell
yeah dude
28% um anyway dude then I went to do go
up on stage and I I did the the Brian K
thing and it was fun um and
uh but I think the main thing is never
trust people you work with you know only
trust people that is your family or you
know if they've been in your life for a
long time I don't know whatever [__]
John Gotti turned on Samy the bulano and
then he turned on him so it's like you
know lar Nostra yeah right and you know
I don't say this too I don't say this
enough but l no yeah
right
um Rick Ross has a bunker hey dude I
know you know we knew right even though
we didn't know we knew that was the next
thing for him for sure it's going down
y'all know how I love real estate and I
usually like to Bild and go up
look we going underground now one time
for all my Doomsday Preppers Elon mus I
see you I saw your ground plans I'm
impressed but guess what he always
sounds like he just got over a sinus
infection what my bunker going to have a
garage my bunker going to have wings my
bunker going to have wings like like
buffalo wings or like it's going to fly
cuz honestly
neither of those things are important
your bunker should stay underground
maybe he means he's going to have a
plane go into the bunker a garage with a
plane this guy Lex Luther um huh yeah
you said it breaking ground huge
excavations you got to have your
fluids
what a [__] dude huge excavations you
got to have your
fluids dude huge excavations
that's
amazing I got a water maker something
like a machine that makes water out of
H2O water is
H2O
ow I got a water maker we got our canned
goods not impressive
dude so if you thinking the brothers
ain't ready
We
Ready
dude we breaking ground you know this
guy's so bored there's you can't every
time you look at a uh Rick
Ross video you're like oh well dude
you're
bored that's it that's what it is we're
breaking
ground I'm Excavating just learning
learned it just learned the word
somebody said used the word Excavating
this is exactly what happened to Rick
Ross somebody used the word Excavating
in a sentence and he said what's that
and they said it's like Excavating it's
like when you when you like take out a
bunch of uh ground you know what it is
it's like if you want to make a bunker
you go into the ground and you excavate
excavate the the ground to make the
bunker and that was what made him want
to do a bunker I guarantee it dude I
promise no doubt dude you say what could
it have we
wings that's what he did and it were
like wings like buffalo
wings could you have a garage in it uh
yeah you can have a garage in the bunker
as long as the ramp goes
down I usually build up though you could
build
down it's going down y'all know how I
love real estate and I usually like to
build and go up
build we going underground now one time
for all my Doomsday Preppers honestly
the ation about the word excavate
excavation happened 4 minutes before
this he recorded this and then he
decided and now he's going to do it Elon
Musk I see you I saw your ground PL I'm
impressed but guess what my bunker going
to have a
garage my bunker going to have
wings huh didn't hear
himself uh
unbelievable but congratulations dude
cuz he's basically a scientist if he can
make uh water at H2O that's amazing dude
he's he's very
Christlike
um that's just
wild dude did you see the did you see
American Nightmare on Netflix I watch
this and I think everybody's watching
this because this is why not only is it
number one on Netflix this is why I
think everyone's watching it I was on
the plane and you know who was on the
plane with me on the way to Phoenix
Sugar Ray Mark McGrath you know the guy
who sings every morning when you wake up
and you're walking dancing I need more
one more bed shut the door baby don't
say a word
ho baby baby you know that song right
what is that called shut the door baby
don't say a word every morning and I
wake up in his it in a one night B to
the door baby don't say a word loud
singer anyway um he was watching it on
my plane so on his phone so everyone has
seen it as soon as Mark McGrath has seen
it he's also the guy who hosts extra
extra I think whenever he used to do
that for like three weeks or something
but
anyway
um somebody who has a place in Phoenix
but so
uh uh he looked like a cool dude I
didn't talk to him I meant to say hi
because you know when you you're a
famous person you see another famous
person you got to be like yo what's up
um but anyway America nightmare is crazy
dude the the show on Netflix American
Nightmare is absolutely crazy dude Okay
so it's basically you probably seen it
but if you haven't it's basically this
guy and girl who live together and
this guy this other person comes in duct
tapes him blindfolds him kidnaps the
woman for a ransom takes the woman and
is and tries to get a ransom from the
from the uh boyfriend okay the boyfriend
goes to the cops the cops think he's
making it up all right they think he's
making it up the FBI gets involved and
they they think that they're trying to
put one over on
them like Gone Girl when of the FBI goes
uh agents is actually like well you know
you seen gong girl right this is what
they're doing hey get a labotomy dude
first of all these two people were
interviewed and they couldn't have sound
more sounded more like they were telling
the
truth man I'm trying to think if my wife
got
kidnapped
and I'm trying to think if my wife got
kidnapped and then I was
like bound or whatever and they
unbounded me and then she was gone and I
got to the police like I would
immediately call the police okay like
cuz they were like do not call the
police I be like this okay I won't I I
swear to God I won't they leave I go
like
this hello police hey my wife was
kidnapped I don't care if they kill me
at that point you know what I'm saying
like I got to do what I got to do I'm
not going to not you know you're not
going to trust this [__] so
um and then if they were like okay why
don't you come down and talk talk to us
and give us a statement and I'm like
well
dude
okay but but holy [__] [__] if they
started being
like if they pulled one of
those [__] first of all if they
pulled one of those [__] you know
when they have the good cop the bad cop
you know when you're in when they when
they when you see the footage of the
interrogation room and you see the cops
moving in on the guy and the guy's in
the corner and they sit they they keep
moving their chairs Clos up by the end
they're like literally right here with
them dude okay let me tell you
something
you can't let that happen I I if I ever
get interrogated for something dude hey
let me tell you something it's me who's
moving the chair up okay go ahead no no
no bring the good cop bring the bad cop
bring a medium cop I don't give a [__]
bring a kid cop and an old cop bring all
the cops you got dude I'm moving the
chair forward I'm getting closer you
move one forward I move two forward okay
until we get so close I kiss you okay
copper
like no [__] you don't do this so so
okay so what I'm trying to do is and
there's a lot of holes in this story I
pull forward no there's
notah book me for
that did you just kiss me yep sorry my
bad 5 I thought that's what you wanted
cuz you were invading my personal
[Music]
space where's the other guy oh you moved
away oh and then I move closer to that
guy dude flip the script Judo these
[__] these cops that can come
all on you and [__] interrogate you
knees to knees [__] that M lips to lips
dude lips to nose
Mah no dude that drives me that so
drives me hey and then none of them go
like this yo back
up [__]
man I know 100% if my wife got kidnapped
that they would think it was me anyway
you know I pray pray my wife never gets
murdered if my wife gets murdered dude
100% 100% the [__] media will say
it's me I I I I already know that I pray
she doesn't get
[__] please nobody murder my wife for
Real uh that goes for everybody in my
family my dad everyone it's just like
they're going to be
like
anyway
dude this is an iced coffee not a drink
people are like oh he drinks
now um so anyway American Nightmare was
like this crazy uh thing where they
thought you know and then like three
days later the the woman came back to
the house and then they thought that the
woman was in on it trying to get money
from the guy and they were like hey we
just love each other guys okay can you
just help there's a guy out there
murdering and and raping can you just
can you just please help and then he
ended up getting someone
else uh
so you know just so
crazy and they were
like ah [__] I don't know dude just I
just don't ever murder anyone around me
please everyone will think it's me I
guarantee it this guy bivo got new
teeth hold on let's look at this thing
here you got new teeth this is the guy
that I was making fun of last time
listen beo here you know the rules
listen we all know bivo is in Turkey
he's finally got his nashers done listen
behind this remote I've got some sick
well you know what I didn't realize when
he blocks his
mouth he actually has the worst hair
I've ever seen in my life it's a it's a
butt crack you know what I mean but
listen 6:00 p.m. English time I'm going
to go live so it be 9:00 p.m. my time
I'm going to go live we're going to do a
reveal but big up the teeth big up UK
Smiles as well listen it's been a it's
been a long week but it's definitely
been worth it I'm um I'm so happy to
finally say get my teeth done and just
enjoy why everyone as well shout out to
Billy shout out to
Sam as well at UK Smiles um yeah it's
been amazing it's been a great
experience they're doing a little UK
tour as well what's going on I'm going
to try and turn up and just show my got
my got my teeth done I'm I'm going put
the reveal it's like appreciation and
just convince people that they know what
they're
getting but yeah 600 p.m. English
time I'm going to go live and we're
going to reveal my smile but big up to
yourselves much love big up beo as soon
as my teeth are calmed down a bit I'll
start doing eating videos but yeah sorry
being active but big up to yourselves
chat to you soon as soon as my as soon
as my teeth as soon as my teeth have
calmed down I do some eating vide videos
for you the weirdest
sentence anyway we saw his teeth uh we
put up a picture of his teeth right
there but they're wild dude when people
get their teeth
done I would be so if I was gonna get my
teeth done which I I wouldn't because
your boy got some nice teeth actually
you get some nice Chompers
dude
um a little they're a little crooked but
I I you know people get their teeth
whitened or done whitened or or
straightened and they end up looking
like the mask and [__] no dude let me
tell you something okay before you get
your teeth done look in the mirror first
and do
this if you if it's too much like the
mask don't get your [__] teeth
done dude that's the [__] should I
get my teeth done test look in the
mirror and
go if you [__] look dumb doing it of
course you look dumb but if you look
extra dumb like the mask you go you know
what I'm gonna actually cool off I get
my teeth done cuz man I heard it two if
you get them whitened man my
ex-girlfriend got the zingers dude
that's what they call them they get
zingers where they [__] K dude she
called me she was in Texas she called me
I was I was at home and she was in Texas
she was like I I this is the most pain
I've ever felt in my life I can't even
deal with it and she was crying I was
like dude it's probably fine dude
apparently it gets so painful but yeah
her teeth were fine she didn't need it
to get whitened anyway big up for big up
for her big up to her um
yeah
and uh so that's it about
that
um what's this an amateur won the golf
tournament and can't do it I heard you
babe um 24 old 20-year-old amateur
golfer just won a PJ Tour event but he's
not allowed to collect the $1.5 million
prize why because he's an amateur what
bro those [__] [__] dude
start to GoFundMe for him he's Rich
anyway he does golf you know Nick Dunlap
reacts after making the putt dude an
amateur beat him they're so mad this is
basically what's it called happy ma
Happy Madison happy what's his name is
that Happy Gilmore it's basically Happy
Gilmore the guy goes like at the end he
goes like
this why can't I get the 1.5 million H
about
who that's
awesome good for you dude
Rael
riseo
um I don't know
oh oh dude the razy awards that's like
the worst stuff razi nominations led by
Expendables um I think we're done using
the numbers to be a letter in the sequel
of a movie title you know what I'm
saying expend four bbls like that that
[__] it's not an a it's a four and We
Know It And it's like not cute anymore
that was cute in like
2001 with
Tupac
um M so do they have the worst picture
here we go oh I love it I love it okay
worst picture The Exorcist Expendables
Meg 2 Shazam Winnie the Poo so okay to
me Expendables absolutely not going to
be in that category period cannot be in
the category cuz you know what you're
going to see when you go see The
Expendables all right you're going to
see ass kicking action it can't be the
worst movie okay that's out Meg 2 kind
of the same not as much as The
Expendables but you know you're going to
see a [__] stupid movie about a big
gigantic shark and also it's a sequel
the first one was shitty so you know
that the second one's going to be shitty
all right so you take Expendables you
take Meg 2 out all
right The Exorcist believer can be in it
because it took itself way too seriously
you saw the previews they tried to act
like it was too scary like it was real
the the the the the posters of that
scary little girl you know so The
Exorcist can believe can be in it all
right Shazam Fury of the Gods can
absolutely be in it all right because it
looks so [__] bad and it's a DC movie
and DC sucks to
Heaven except for the uh Suicide Squad
right um and
also it Shazam you know like nobody
gives a [__] about that
Superhero Winnie the Pooh Blood and
Honey the scary movie it's a horror
movie about Winnie the Pooh that cannot
be in the Razzy Awards as worst you know
going to watch a horror movie about
Winnie the Pooh is going to be bad you
know it's going to be bad you know it's
going to to be what it is H going to
kill you you know that's bad under no
circumstance you go in thinking like I
can't wait to get my socks knocked off
of me I can't wait to see Winnie the
Pooh put down his honey pick up a
plastic bag and suffocate
someone in no way do you come out a
different person after that movie all
right so the only movies that can be in
the worst picture are Exorcist and
Shazam
and I bet it's
Shazam I bet The Exorcist is just
another horror movie that's also bad
Shazam is probably piss [__] poor
figured it out without seeing any of
them although we know that Wonder Woman
1980 whatever was the [__] one that
should have won the Razzi Awards or the
new Matrix was the one how is that not
nominated the new Matrix was one of the
worst movies I've ever seen in my life
dude ever seen in my life it was the gay
gayest movie of all time the gay tricks
um look at this how shitty would it be
to be nominated for worst
actor ad the razio look Russell Crow the
Pope's Exorcist so shitty you know
you're talking about Gladiator you're
talking about the guy who did The
Insider you're talking about the guy
who's done [__] LA Confidential
you're talking about a guy who could
take his Aussie New Zealand acent and
just toss it out and be an Irish guy you
talk about m beautiful mind and you give
him the [__] Razzy nomination for
worst actor Vin Diesel fast X yes now I
understand facts is what it is and it's
supposed to be stupid but Vin
Diesel I've got one question for Vin
Diesel
how how did this get past period you
know this was after Schwarzenegger
Stallone Jet Lee Statham [__] uh even
St them yeah uh uh uh Van Dam this was
after all that [__] now look some of the
guys turned out to be a great actor
Stallone is a good actor but dude how do
how did Vin Diesel do this he's this he
is just Vin Diesel so he deserves Razzy
for worst actor nomination Jason
Stam nah I don't come on John Voit Mercy
what even is that Chris Evans ghosted I
don't know Chris Evans is a good actor
but what the [__] ghosted just that
should be worst movie of all time
probably all right worst actress Su hyek
Megan
Fox Jennifer Lopez come on this not
right look at this look we're sporting
actors again Megan Fox and Expendable
somebody hates [__] Megan spox over
at [__] the Razzi
Awards worst supporting actor Mill
Gibson of course because all the stuff
he said about Jews again I'm giv r word
Michael Douglas and anman no way we
don't stand for Michael Douglas Lander
no
way look Frank Franco Nero as the Pope
in the pope sacri God who [__] what
what do they watch like seven movies and
just why is the pope Exorcist so high on
this list for
them look worst screen couple any two in
merciless mercenaries any two money
grubbing investors who donated $400
million remake rights to the ex 40
million for the Remake rights four four
sorry 400 million for the Remake rights
of Exorcist are you [__] me
wow um this is so funny worst prequel
remake ripoff or sequel Ant-Man Exorcist
Expendables I mean there's six movies on
this [__]
thing worst
director and of course believer Exorcist
and of course [__] Expendables and of
course Meg 2 where screenplay let me
guess wow so Exorcist Expendables Shazam
win Theo and Indiana Jones so what what
didn't get it for worst picture so Meg 2
didn't make the worst script so oh no
they did sorry wait worst
script yeah Meg 2 so so the movie Meg 2
was bad the script was not not the
worst wow
insane look at [__] like this AI
recreated how these dead stars would
have aged you know if you have ever
clicked on anything like
that you know
I mean I probably have but
um everyone is so
so I
um
um look at this CNN article reys
Witherspoon eating snow did Disturbed
people she would like a word hey
CNN you
doing um she posted a Tik Tok which had
some fun with some new fallen snow look
at the way they write this [__] you know
the way they write it all glossy it's
still a piece of [__] the morning show
star uh recently posted a Tik Tok video
in which she had some fun with some new
fallen snow hey your CNN though you you
know what I mean uh in the video two
mugs were used to scoop snow off a car
with spoon then describ just have
uh anyway
she she posted her
recipe who cares about any of
this look somebody comments no no no
snow is not made to eat you can
seriously get sick one person commented
man the internet [__] everything up
huh what about childhood dude you can
eat snow it's fine I mean I I eat I ate
snow when I was a kid I'm sure dogs
pissed on it I I I ate that [__] and I'm
fine he said [__] his pants with no
one knew even even though he was live on
his
podcast um look at this we drank out of
the T yeah that's the another um we
drank out of the top we actually yeah we
I never really drank out of the top man
I did drink out of the top I did yeah
you drink out of the hose I've done that
too yeah and I guess you can't do that
now the bottle the water bottle the
water uh industry is a racket
right look at this stupid headline
there's no big secret why Vince vaugh
isn't around anymore dude if it was no
big secret then we wouldn't need an
article about it also dude CNN is the
tabloids
um anyway dude whatever I did this
[__] thing soft white underbelly it's
awesome uh I love it I'm a big fan of it
the guy asked me to do it he uh Mark
Mark Lea wanted me to do it uh because
he was like he wants to like Branch out
and start doing like you know Comedians
and actors and writers and [__] like
that I don't know but I was I like yeah
[__] yeah I'll do it I did it and um it
was really cool I I you know I don't say
I had fun doing it we talked about some
you know some some light-hearted stuff
and then some some hardcore [__] and uh
and it was it was cool a lot and and
um the the [__] I checked a few of
the comments and I was like all right I
guess I can't look at this dude people
are just [__] so it's so wild
dude like people are just like they want
you to die you know they're like nah
[__] you can't you can't if
somebody says hey you did this you can't
even be like no I didn't people are like
oh nah but you need to take
accountability you
can't take accountability for something
you didn't do and they really want you
to do that [__] dude but um anyway I did
the [__] interview and it was it was
really cool I'm a big fan of soft soft
white underbelly belly um and of course
like I know I made mistakes uh of course
of course I know I made mistakes um and
both of those things are true so uh
anyway uh it was cool it was worth doing
and I really enjoy that uh that channel
it's crazy but it'll just be like now
it's hilarious because it'll just be
like it'll be like prostitute fentanyl
addict uh serial killer uh uh murderer
the devil
crystalia comedian you
know uh [__] what's uh uh Warden to
San
Quinton uh
uh uh victim of John Wayne gasy and then
comedian Chrystal Leah and it's like
okay
um you don't want people to [__] say
what they feel and be honest then then
nobody's going to you know nobody's
going to they just want you to shut the
[__] up that it's just the craziest
World dude it is the craziest [__]
world they just want you to shut the
[__] up and eat
crow
um look at this [__] Taylor Swift and K
Travis Kelce
um I don't I can't imagine caring about
something more than hey you know that
football player is dating uh the [__]
singer and then you go oh really huh
well that's weird I thought he liked
black chicks H maybe it's a PR thing H
maybe they love each other and then
that's
it that's
it but I don't give a [__] I'm happy for
them that they're you know love each
other of course they're going to break
up she gonna make a song about it this
is all part of it and then his career is
going to be over because he's gonna you
know he's not going to do as
well um and then there's going to be be
something like what do you call it the
tayor Swift curse like don't date Taylor
Swift like how if Drake mentions you
before a fight you die or whatever it is
a UFC
fight
um I don't understand how somebody can
be as famous as T Taylor Swift this is
why I don't like like when you see like
[__] like Tom Cruz like you know he's a
Scientologist and he's crazy like of
course of course dude if I was that
famous you understand if I was that
famous I would part of me would think oh
well
but in my past life I was shoes you know
like I would just think crazy [__] like
that I would think absolute nutty [__] I
would be like well we're probably in the
Matrix and I just like have the most
money and so I paid to have the best
life but it comes with its troubles so
huh isn't that funny even in when you're
plugged in you you you know the stuff
you can't buy happiness like this is the
[__] I would be thinking
of I don't know how you stay sane the
fact that Taylor Swift hasn't murdered
murdered people means that she's an a a
higher level being than I am Tom Cruz is
just a Scientologist are you kidding me
the guy should be a warlord dude if I
got to Tom Cruz level warlord straight
up I'd have my own
country um my laugh would be different
I'd be
like you
know um I I just don't under a
microscope like
that
crazy anyone see that movie [__] uh
killer of the flower Moon Yeah I want to
see that you see it is it good it's so
long though dude three and a half hours
didn't feel long I watch Oppenheimer I'm
like all right I'll watch flowers killer
flowers Moon next year Oppenheimer was
great but man three hours is that's it I
can do three but I can't three and a
half bro what is this Gettys B remember
that [__] movie that was like four
something long it had an intermission in
the theater you go out and pee and get
popcorn and come back and they're still
[__] sawing each other's legs off
it's like oh Jesus
man
um anyway um yeah that's good we had a
good episode today thank you very much
I'll be in El Paso Albuquerque chris.com
and go stream my special chris.com have
a good one um and also uh check our
patreon out the patreon is why this
podcast keeps going Patriot Don
patriot.com
christalia uh please subscribe we love
it leave a comment um you guys are the
you guys are the greatest thank you for
this absolutely beautiful episode 361 I
think